there is truth and there are lies the
dream of justice for all
will be deferred no longer growing
inequity
a sting of systemic racism a climate in
crisis
we must end this uncivil war
it was mainly kind of pablum
but here's the thing when people use
deliberately vague terminology
like unity without defining what they
mean by unity when they use deliberately
vague
language like truth versus lies but they
don't define what they mean by truth and
what they mean by
lies and when they say that they're a
bunch of crises that are racking the
nation and they misdefine the crises
this is the predicate for something that
does not look like it's going to solve
crisis
something that does not look like truth
and something that does not look like
unity so this has been biden schtick
since the beginning of his candidacy is
that he was going to be a unifying
figure
in american public life he's a weird guy
to do it i mean just to begin with he's
a very
partisan democrat he was a very partisan
democrat when he was in the united
states senate
he was a very partisan democrat when he
was barack obama's vice president he
famously stated in 2012 that mitt romney
was going to put black people back
in chains but put that to the side he
was going to be a unifying figure and
frankly
sounds nice i mean we've been very
polarized people have been at each
other's throats
culminating in a really ugly scene on
january 6th at the capitol riot but the
question is what does he mean
by unity so here is joe biden talking
about unity
and his suggestion is that in order for
there to be peace there must be unity
for without unity there is no peace
only bitterness and fury no progress
only exhausting outrage no nation
only a state of chaos and when joe biden
says something like there has to be
unity before there can be peace you
gotta wonder what does he mean by unity
does he mean
that disagreement is going to be widely
allowed or does he mean that if you
disagree with me
i'm going to suggest that you are now
disunifying and polarizing and wrecking
the beautiful unity
that would prevail in the absence of
your stupid descent i'm not
judging joe biden this early on i'm
asking whether joe biden is going to
decide with the left whether he's going
to side with the democratic base
or whether he actually means what he
says and he presumes that he is going to
uphold
basic american principle and then
dissent within that principle okay and
that brings us
to number two okay again a vague
statement that can be interpreted a
couple of ways he talks a lot about
truth versus lies
recent weeks and months have taught us a
painful lesson
there is truth and there are lies
lies told for power and for profit
the problem of course is that again when
it comes to our politics there are a lot
of folks on the left who don't agree
with that they just agree
with what they agree with to folks on
the left it is a simple fact that
america was rooted in racism for example
to a lot of folks on the left it is a
simple fact that the police are
systemically bigoted to a lot of folks
on the left it is a simple fact
that the gender pay gap is due to
instinctive and
and ingrained american sexism right all
of these are considered facts now
everything i just said
each one of those statements is an
opinion it happens to be based on very
scanty evidence
when joe biden says that we have to
distinguish between facts
and lies does he mean that in the very
real sense in which 2 plus 2 equals 4
and 2 plus 2
equals 5 are not the same or does he
mean things i disagree with will be
considered as though they are lies
and things i agree with will be
considered as though they are fact this
is a very
very important question because during
the obama administration it was very
much the latter okay which brings us
to the third theme of biden's inaugural
address and that was the crises that
america faces a cry for racial justice
some 400 years in the making moves us
the dream of justice for all will be
deferred no longer
okay that is a political statement it is
not an objective statement of fact there
is
no crisis of race relations in the
united states
other than the opinions that people hold
without race relations and the solutions
that he's going to propose
for that as we'll talk about in a second
are going to verge
on the racially discriminatory
themselves and then finally he talked
about climate change as an existential
crisis
for the united states the solutions that
he has proposed to climate change are
utterly ineffectual he has yet to prove
that it is a crisis on the level of the
immediate and if he is talking about the
crisis
that is supposed to occur over the
course of the next 100 years he has not
proposed any solutions that are directed
towards solving
that crisis those are the themes of his
speech unity which is
again an empty vessel it's got to be
filled in facts versus lies
empty vessel has to be filled in and
crises two of the four that he mentions
are controversial to say the least which
brings us to the
second issue here so for a guy who is
unifying you would assume that he would
find some consensus policies and then he
would build around those consensus
policies
there are certain areas of american life
where there happens to be fairly wide
bipartisan support
biden with his initial executive orders
is jumping precisely into the areas
where there is not
significant american bipartisan support
so to take a perfect example
he has decided that he is throwing out
the 1776 commission this was a
commission begun by president
trump it was meant to rebut the 1619
project which is a fictionalized piece
of propaganda put out by nicole hannah
jones
and the new york times the basic idea of
which is that america is rooted in and
steeped in racism
and bigotry so trump put together a
commission that was supposed to
re-inculcate american values and rebut a
lot of those ideas
biden's killing that one immediately he
suggested that he's going to simply stop
enforcing immigration laws
in certain ways the same way that barack
obama did so as to make it a lot easier
to illegally immigrate to the united
states
he has suggested he's going to jump
right back into the paris climate
accords the paris climate accords are
maybe the most useless piece of paper
ever written upon they basically suggest
that a bunch of nations are going to
commit to targets that they have no
proposals for actually hitting but the
goal is to shame everybody who is not a
member of the paris climate accords he's
appointing people
who are unqualified for their positions
solely on the basis of their identity
groups he has a new assistant secretary
of health and human services who is
transgender that is the only headline
that is positive about this person
this person also happens to have been
the secretary of health and human
services
in the state of pennsylvania who shipped
covert positive old people back into
nursing homes
so on the con side would be killed a
bunch of olds
in pennsylvania via covid and on the
pros would be
is a man who believes that he is a woman
we have heard from janet yellen and
people
in the economic side of the biden
administration that they wish to
immediately rethink american policy on
the basis of quote-unquote racial equity
which is to suggest discrimination
because the idea here is not that we are
going to try to create a functioning
economy
that works and it generates prosperity
the idea is going to be that if there's
inequality between racial groups
that can be rectified by
redistributionism between racial groups
via economic policy and we've heard that
joe biden wants to put back in place the
entire team that negotiated the iran
nuclear deal
a deal that was in fact so damaging
to a lot of our allies in the middle
east that it ended up
almost solving the israeli arab dispute
because so many people hated the iran
nuclear deal
and his allies in congress are
encouraging him that if he can't get
congressional support for this sort of
stuff
as james clyburn suggested he should
just go ahead and do it from the top
if they're going to be recastleton if
they're going to throw up roadblocks
go on without them use your executive
authority
if they refuse to cooperate is that
unity
does that sound like truth versus lies
that brings us to
the final question here which is okay
what do we do about it as conservatives
what do we do about all of this stuff
alrighty so joe biden tends to put me to
sleep i mean he tends to put himself to
sleep but if he puts you to sleep and
you actually need to stay awake
you need coffee and that means you need
an excellent cold brew maker because
cold brew coffee is better than hot brew
it's not as acidic it's not as bitter
this is why you need the presto dorothy
rapid cold brew maker
checking this baby out oh yeah dorothy
makes delicious cold brew
in minutes i'm going to show you how
this thing works okay so you've seen me
attempt to actually cook a turkey so you
know i'm not competent with things
but i can actually use this so here is
how your dorothy
cold brew maker works first you take
some water you pour it on in
all the way up to the line then you just
turn it on
and very very soon you will see
the tornado begin to form you see that
tornado look how cool that is
now you take this your medium ground
coffee
you put that in there then you just brew
it to your desired strength like 10
minutes for a light brew and 15 for
medium roast and then
like for a dark brew then you go 20
minutes when you reach your desired
strength
you let the coffee rest for five minutes
you take the plunger
put it here push it down you separate
out the grounds
and now you're ready to go
it is indeed that simple head on over to
getdorothy.com that is get dorothy.com
click buy now add to cart enter promo
code shapiro get 10
off and free shipping
literally every major institution in
american life is now run
by people who are censorious people who
do not like your opinions people who
wish to ostracize you
and extirpate you in some cases from
american public life
corporate america is dominated by people
who are willing to go along with the
woke encourage you if you disagree
the media are all in on the idea that
their opposition ought to be wiped off
the earth
these companies have freedom of speech
but i'm not sure we need
verizon at t comcast and such to be
bringing them into
tens of millions of homes right we are
seeing this in social media as well
directly
where the tech bros have decided that
they are simply going to cave to the
democrats in the hope that they will be
left alone
or they actually agree with democrats
that a lot of the language they don't
like
is now going to be considered dangerous
and ought to be banned okay so what do
we do about it
one make sure that you actually get out
and work for
republican congressional candidates in
2022 there is another election coming up
the party out of power typically does
very well in the off-year elections
right now the democrats have the
slimmest governing majority in the house
of representatives
in several generations that can easily
be flipped easily be flipped but that
means that republicans have to get out
there and work they don't just have to
get out there and work for candidates
they have to pressure their legislatures
and legislators at the state level
to redo how voting is done so we don't
have the fiasco that was universal mail
and balloting
this time it means better voter
verification it means voter id it is to
suggest you need to vote on the day that
the election
is held and you better have a good
excuse for not doing it that way
and it better be you when you actually
vote right that would help as well you
need to get
senator joe manchin on your speed dial
so senator joe manchin
is the sole force right now militating
against the death of the filibuster in
the united states senate if he starts to
waver on that i'm going to give you his
phone number right now if you're a west
virginian citizen particularly
you need to sound off to your senator if
he starts to waver on that principle one
iota his number
is
him from 304-342-5855 fundamental norms
and getting rid of the filibuster once
the filibuster is gone democrats can
with a simple
50 plus kamala harris vote add states
like washington dc and puerto rico
adding four democratic senators
they can move forward theoretically with
packing the supreme court they could
move forward
with completely rewriting broad swaths
of american law
so joe manchin stands between the
republic
in that sense and a sort of crack up
that faces us if with a
the barest of bare majorities democrats
start cramming down extraordinary
top-down policy
states that are read should start
protecting their citizens from the
predations of national institutions
if the social media bros decide that
they are simply going to violate
these sort of free speech rights that
you would have whether it's a public
sector company
by cracking down on dissent in
monopolistic fashion right coordinating
and then all deciding that certain views
are
out of the debate and out of the domain
of normal public discourse
states are going to have to step in
you've started to see this in some
states proposals being put forth
that any isp that discriminates any
cable provider that discriminates
on the basis of politics any social
media network that discriminates on the
basis of politics
will not be able to operate in a
particular state that restrictions will
be placed
on those companies i'm not a fan of
using this sort of interventionism with
regard to these companies but if the
companies have basically centralized all
the power to control your speech in the
public
forum then i don't see a whole hell of a
lot of protections outside of state
governments especially if the federal
government
is forcing a lot of this conservatives
are going to have to get very active in
the legal arena democrats have for
decades
use the power of the judicial branch in
order to get policy done that they
couldn't get done
at the legislative level people on the
right need to coordinate in terms of the
lawsuits that they are filing in order
to uphold their rights in the face of
discrimination
on the basis of religion or violation of
freedom of religion on the basis of
free speech rights and all these things
are going to have to get litigated
in court and then finally on an
interpersonal level we're going to have
to talk with one another
we're going to have to stop hunkering
down in the silos that we've built for
ourselves
and we're gonna actually have to start
talking with one another convincing one
another
treating each other with respect weirdly
enough that's exactly what joe biden
advocated for
in his inaugural address i hope that he
takes it seriously i certainly do
and i hope that we have those
conversations if we do then i
think that the next few years could
actually be bright i think that we could
actually start moving
beyond the partisan polarization that we
have seen i don't have a lot of faith if
that's what's going to happen
but i think that if you engage with your
neighbors and with your family then that
is the the best possible outcome and
that will shift hearts and that will
shift minds and will make people
more conservative over the course of
time final note there's one other thing
you should do and that is you should
support
alternative institutions to the
institutions that exist and are
discriminating against conservatives and
intend to crack down on conservatives if
you don't like the establishment media
and their sycophantic approach to the
news their activist approach to the news
on the left
support places like daily wire if you
don't like what hollywood is cramming
down upon you in terms of values don't
support them take your money elsewhere
if you want to fight back against
institutions that do not share your
values
you're gonna have to build your own this
is not my preferred state of affairs i
would prefer
that all of these people just butt out
of politics entirely and then we can
have robust debates at the water cooler
but
if american life continues to grow more
and more political in each and every
arena there's only one choice and that
is to create
alternatives as every other american
should i pray
for the president of the united states
to do the right thing
to do the right thing i don't care who
the president is i want the president to
do the right thing because he works for
us if he does the wrong thing we need to
counter it
if he does the right thing we need to
celebrate it i hope to god that joe
biden does many of the right things even
though i fear he won't
i hope that he does if not we're going
to have to check him
if you agree that we need to stand
together to fight back against the
predations of the new administration
against the predations of institutions
that don't share your values
then please number one give us a like on
the video and two share the video with
your friends and family
everybody on all sides should be able to
have real unity
that unity should come in the shape of
america's fundamental rights and
fundamental values is embodied in the
declaration of independence
and constitution that's the side we
should all be on anybody who is not
on that side needs to be named called
out and fought against we need to stand
strong
and we need to fight back against any
predations on our rights we can do that
together